in the purge election year joe's deli
serves as a symbol for the american
dream for jonah's community but some of
the images seen around the store have a
greater significance than you might have
realized election year shows us the
height of a revolution
staged by the lower class against the
government this is essentially the new
civil rights movement of the united
states in the world of the purge the
poor are discriminated against not only
can the wealthy better afford to protect
themselves during the purge but if you
read into the lore detailed on the new
founder's website you'll see that
they've enacted laws like the
contributing citizens provision of 2019
that straight up allow discrimination
against the poor
there are both subtle and not so subtle
comparisons to the original civil rights
movement that took place in the united
states 86 years prior
joe's deli is his pride and joy his
little piece of the pie as he puts it
for him
the american dream means owning and
operating his own business that serves
the community but his dream like the
dream of his ancestor martin luther king
jr is crushed when his insurance company
intentionally raises his rates one day
before the purge
it just raised the premium on my purge
coverage by thousands
the day before the damn purge if i don't
pay it by tomorrow i have no purge
coverage for this story
in previous purge movies we've learned
that weapon and home security companies
are the most likely shills for the
political party that created the purge
the nffa an election year suggests that
insurance companies have joined that
category
but some of the images seen in and
around the delhi are more than just a
generic symbol of civil rights they
reference specific historical events
that foreshadow what happens at the end
of the movie there are also more modern
references in fact election year may
have actually predicted some future
events so stick around to the end of
this video to hear all about it
this video is sponsored by audible
i hereby proclaim that all men shall
subscribe to cz's world
and ring the death bell for all
notifications
welcome to things you missed if you've
been waiting for a video where emo
abraham lincoln regular abraham lincoln
and angry abraham lincoln all collide
this is the episode for you
if you want to hear about the hidden
meanings encoded in the third purge
movie you are also
in the right place this would be the
last installment directed by series
creator james demonico although he would
stay on as a screenwriter going forward
if you look at election year literally
it looks like the silliest most
ridiculous entry but we can find deeper
meaning when looking at a metaphorical
level
let's get into it
[Music]
all around washington dc there are nffa
logos and advertisements but in
low-income areas like the area near the
freeway underpass and right around the
deli we see that the banners have been
to phase
a symbol of the tension that exists
between the social classes the divide
between the rich and poor is highlighted
by the use of technology the movie is
set in 2040 so you'd expect some
futuristic gadgets like leo's remote
detonating briefcase and
gps tracking bullets but joe marcos and
laney use devices that feel outdated
even today
from standard definition monitors to
broken grandpa clocks to samsung galaxy
s2s and
even this monstrosity as i mentioned the
deli is decorated with photos of the
most prominent figures of the original
civil rights movements like malcolm x
who is an advocate of african-american
human rights in the 1960s who is
criticized for refusing to denounce
violence as a form of self-defense
well martin is your friend yet you would
disagree with his uh
approach to what he wants to accomplish
definitely if his approach
would bring about what the black man in
america needs
to completely eliminate the problem that
we have i would say well and good the
purge election
year has its own malcolm x it's dante
bishop the homeless man turned
revolutionary fighter who planned to
assassinate the nffa's presidential
candidate
the independent candidate charlie rohn
criticizes him on his methods
mr bishop i've heard stories
of tactics that you employ on fire
tonight
i can't say that i agree with any of it
bishop changes his ways in the end but
they do share the same fate of being
taken out by extremists another picture
seen in the deli is of harriet tubman
harriet was born into slavery in the
1820s and her most notable
accomplishment was operating the
underground railroad a network of secret
routes and safe houses designed to help
escort african americans out of slavery
in the south the new civil rights
movement isn't about slavery and race
though it's about
money and homelessness so the new
harriet tubman is laini rucker who
spends her purge night working in a
triage van to help purge victims get to
underground safe houses throughout the
city where they can hide out and get
medical attention
tubman also worked as a nurse during the
american civil war and notably led a
military
operation known as the raid on kombahi
ferry where 750 people were rescued from
slavery on union ships
at one point laney's character is
implied to also have some kind of
notable military background but it's
never explained or expanded upon and
isn't relevant to the story in any way
that's laney record kimmy lainey rucker
they called you begenyam little dad
you're my [ __ ] this detail
seems to only exist to explain how she
knows how to use a gun or as an added
parallel to harriet tubman
then there's frederick douglass like the
others he was an important figure in
slavery abolition and civil rights he
went on to hold several political
offices and at one point he was
nominated
to become the vice president of the
united states if he does have a
counterpart in the movie i'm guessing
that it's senator rohn but there may be
another historical figure who serves as
a stronger reflection of rome the most
recognizable person pictured here
the true patriot of his time was tom
brady this was before he became a
buccaneer but other than that there's
martin luther king jr who of course is
the most prolific civil rights speaker
of all time with his famous i have a
dream speech
there are a couple of pictures of him in
the deli but i want to look at this one
in particular which was taken at a press
conference on november 5th 1964
just after lyndon b johnson was elected
as president johnson was known for his
domestic policies known as the great
society program
and the war on poverty program which
assisted millions of families out of
poverty during his administration
senator rohn's platform is all about
helping out low-income people primarily
by promising to end the purge the day
this photo was taken and johnson spoke
with king jr to thank him for his
support and asked him to get behind the
poverty initiative
we're gonna spend a lot of time with
shriver on our poverty thing i wish
you'd give a little
thought to it because that offers a lot
of opportunity for
our young people
so as you can see there are a lot of
similarities between senator rohn and
lyndon b johnson but there may be one
more parallel in looking at the
circumstances of when they took
office johnson was elected shortly after
becoming president due to the
assassination of john f kennedy while
rhone was elected shortly after the
assassination of caleb warrens
the nffa leader that gets sniped down at
the end of the movie the main characters
would not be the only ones who represent
a person or group of historical
significance and there would be many
other secrets waiting to be
uncovered
here at the nffa we take president's day
very seriously to honor our great
founding fathers like president bracken
and
president warrens that's why this year
we're teaming up with audible to offer
you a free
30-day trial audible is the leading
provider of spoken word entertainment
with the largest selection of ad-free
audiobooks original entertainment
and podcasts you'll even find guided
fitness meditation and sleep tracks to
keep you healthy before this year's
purge
the newest plan audible plus gives you
full access to the popular
plus catalog all available to download
and stream anywhere on any device
audible plus is all about finding new
favorites or new formats helping you
discover that podcast or audiobook you
wouldn't have even considered before
one title we recommend checking out is
1984 by george orwell we found it very
uplifting and inspirational
to redeem this offer visit audible.com
cz's world or text cz's worlds to
500-500 to start your free 30-day trial
you'll find that link in the description
that's audible.com cz's world or text
cz's world to 500
500.
the previous film the purge anarchy
started to explore how the nffa was
creating a religious aspect to the purge
as part of their wider effort to
manipulate people into participating
here it's front and center as the new
nffa presidential candidate is a
minister who holds a midnight ceremony
on purge night where less fortunate
people and political enemies are to be
sacrificed
there are many moments that build up to
the finale at the cathedral from the
first shot of the evening showing a son
setting behind a building that looks
like a church to a church being the only
location labeled on the gps system that
the nffa's mercenaries use to track the
senator the united states has something
called an establishment clause the
separation of church and states but we
see that all of the new founding fathers
are the religious leaders serving as
ministers and priests this isn't a
separate religion that they happen to be
a part of this is clearly an nffa event
minister owens even admits that midnight
purge mass belongs to his party his
first name is edwidge a french name
meaning war
he is a minister of war and as senator
rohn suggests in debates
murder is his new religion he's joined
at the altar by harmon james harmon is
also a french name
meaning a soldier and he's the one
carrying out the ceremonious purging on
the topic of nomenclature there are a
couple of notable names on the other
side as well
as i mentioned in his horror history
episode dante bishop is given a name for
the first time in this movie previously
only being referred to as a stranger
dante refers to dante's inferno a famous
14th century poem about the journey
through hell while his surname bishop
would refer to the clergy member in the
christian church so his name comes off
as an oxymoron perhaps he splits
somewhere between heaven and hell he has
good intentions and wants to help people
but uses violent tactics to make his
points at the end he has to choose
between sin
and virtue also of note he has a right
hand man whose name is angel
earlier on the streets a crazy purger
chants about the gates of hell
the movie seems to be showing us the
contrast between traditional religious
beliefs where behavior would dictate
going to heaven or hell in the nffa's
new distorted religious system where sin
is glorified one name that we've seen
come up in every purge movie
is sabian arlo sabine was the nfa chief
of staff in the first purge mr sabian
was a neighbor in the purge and a diner
patron in the purge anarchy and now mrs
sabian is a customer at joe's deli
mrs sabian i wish i knew the name sabian
is a staple in every movie made by
director james demonico
as is staten island you can spot some
channel 11 purge coverage of staten
island in the tv in the back of the
senator's living room
and speaking of stuff that appears in
other purge movies were we not supposed
to notice that when the sirens sound
they just ripped an unused shot from the
purge anarchy this is clearly
la my only guess is that they were
trying to encompass how far the purge
series has come with this sequence which
starts in the senator's home the first
movie takes place all inside of one home
and then shows los angeles where the
second movie takes place then shows
washington dc
which is the capital it's representative
of the entire country there's also a
connection to the original film in that
the flashback of rhone's family being
purged takes place in the same night as
that movie before the nfa hired
mercenaries invade her home there were a
few significant items that i noticed
upstairs
like these crane ornaments in japanese
culture cranes are said to represent
good fortune and longevity two traits
that seem appropriate for barnes and
rhone who survive until the next morning
against
all odds there's also a turtle on the
senator's mantle a chinese symbol for
longevity this is seen
just before leo bursts into the room and
has her put on a bulletproof vest
her metaphorical turtle shell if you
will leo and rhone escape it just before
the bad guys break into the room and
their leader unmasked himself revealing
his affiliation with many of the most
evil groups throughout history we've got
to slow it down to understand all of
them the more well-known ones are the
nazi symbol the party responsible for
the holocaust the ku klux klan a white
supremacist group and the confederate
flag of the breakaway state that fought
for slavery in the american civil war he
also has a tattoo that says eighth aid
which is supposedly a numerical code
h is the eighth letter of the alphabet
so this translates to hh which stands
for hale hitler another tattoo says a b
an acronym for aryan brotherhood a
neo-nazi prison gang and organized crime
syndicate my google search history feels
very dirty after looking this stuff up
and that's coming from me
my favorite search result though was
when i looked up what a spiderweb tattoo
on one's head signifies and found the
answer
a serious lapse in judgment upon looking
further i found out it meant that they
were in prison the assault rifle on his
temple signifies that he's a gun carrier
and the words free in america are
written across his face
which isn't a bad message by itself but
takes a darker meaning in the world of
the purge on the back of his head he has
the american eagle i'm guessing it's not
because he's a fan of the clothing brand
or the roller coaster although he does
seem to like spider webs there's also an
american flag
almost as if the us has become the
newest evil group in this universe we
see that the country definitely attracts
negative attention when a story on the
news tells about the latest travel trend
called murder tourism
we had to experience the purge to kill
release all the anger and hate
be like americans i think this is kind
of a commentary on how other countries
see america today where the rate of mass
shootings is much higher than any other
developed country
of course i'm american so i can only
assume how other countries see us there
are also several examples of medieval
weapons like a guillotine a pendulum and
a mace being used to purge which i see
as a symbol for the primitive nature of
weapon regulations in the us
the murder tourists play an interesting
role later in the story as barnes is
trying to escort senator rohn to safety
and they're stalked by a drone which we
later find out to be a russian drone in
other words this american politician is
being followed around by russian spies
the purge election year was released in
2016 which was an election year in real
life for the united states it is said
that russia tried to influence the
results of that election by creating
bots on social media websites to spread
propaganda the drone is literally a
russian bot and when leo shoots it down
the explosion lights up a mural that
says keep washington beautiful
if it's intentional it's an interesting
metaphor i'll just let you decide how
intentional it really is though the
movie came out in july but the election
didn't begin until the end of the year
it's hard to say when the russian
initiative would have begun seeing as
how i'm not a member of the cia or the
fbi
however paranoia of russian plans has
been a concept in american culture that
goes back for decades
that being said the next scene does seem
to predict a russian collusion where bot
accounts on social media pretending to
be american citizens would spread
information that might influence the
election in the purge we have these
russian
tourists masquerading around in
washington dc in the costumes of typical
american icons and they almost quite
literally influence the election by
purging one of the candidates
so we've discussed how many characters
and groups have historical or societal
significance in the story
what about kimmy and her purge gang we
first meet her trying to steal candy
from joe's deli and even when confronted
about it she's resistant to give it up
kimmy represents greed she comes back
during the purge with the intention of
stealing back the candy bar
and i want my candy bar and i'm gonna
take it
when she returns we see that she's
already got it all nice cars decorated
with bright lights bejeweled guns made
of solid gold and flashy costumes
because
the purge is halloween for adults no
halloween as an adult is halloween for
adults
i appreciate the positive energy though
dude kimmy and her gang are basically
the typical american millennial
archetype of course this movie is set in
2040 so they aren't actually millennials
this is just another social commentary
on our own time period
she isn't willing to buy the candy bar
because she feels she just has the
rights to take it
i'll take whatever i want her greed
isn't limited to material things either
she's also a massive attention freak
notice how their crew isn't dressed for
stealth combat like most purgers they
deck their cars out with lights and
blast loud music
they wear skimpy outfits and wear mascot
costumes and anime masks for them
purge is all about being the center of
attention taking whatever they want and
taking out anyone who tries to stop them
her crew is so self-absorbed that they
don't even hear lainey's van driving up
to take them out
this is actually one of many just kind
of dumb moments in this movie like when
leo and the senator encounter the
swinging pendulum and they try to time
it when there's clearly just plenty of
room for them to crawl underneath i feel
like i'm willing to forgive some of the
ridiculousness though because this entry
does have probably my favorite line in
the franchise
we are going to use this year's purge to
do
some spring cleaning gentlemen
the next purge installment would be the
poorly titled prequel the first purge
which i've already covered here on
things you missed when it came out in
2018 but
it doesn't really hold up like i need to
redo the video and make it good this
time
i would always try to do these episodes
when the movie was in theaters to
capitalize on the hype but now that
movies aren't in theaters i realize i
can make a much better episode if i just
take my time with it so
join me in the next things you missed as
we revisit the first purge
remember to subscribe to sisi's world
for new horrors every week ring the
death bell and select
all notifications and i will see you in
the next one
assuming we both survive if you don't
want to get purged
stay home wear a mask if you go out for
essentials you know the drill